[Música]
salud en directo américa ya está conmigo
lista en el estudio más romeros a la mar
bienvenida a félix jueves para ti feliz
mañana vamos a empezar en polonia donde
la depresión y la ansiedad ha aumentado
entre la población lgtb de cv más desde
2017 más repreguntó porque pues el
estudio este lo relaciona especialmente
con el gobierno que ha habido desde 2015
ultraconservador de ley y justicia al
final es un ejemplo más de que nuestro
entorno político en nuestro entorno
social también afecta a nuestra salud y
nuestra salud mental en este caso
recordemos que este partido gobierna en
mayoría desde desde 2015 tiene unas
posiciones especialmente agresivas
contra la población de orientaciones
sexuales no normativas de identidades de
género también no normativas y por eso
es que un estudio de la universidad de
varsovia se puso a ver cómo estaban las
tasas de síntomas de depresión y de
síntomas de ansiedad y vieron que eres
en el número de personas del egb temas
habían pasado prácticamente de un 28 a
un 44% entre 2017 y 2020 raúl tú crees
que al final la orientación sexual es
algo que se pueda cambiar no por
supuesto que no
doctores polacos no piensan lo mismo
escuchemos los testimonios
como fueron los contactos conductores
psiquiatras psicólogos o terapeutas que
a menudo observamos que los
profesionales que los trataban no tenían
ni idea sobre cuestiones como la
orientación sexual o la identificación
personal a menudo sugieren que pueden
curarse o que la orientación sexual es
algo que se puede cambiar como más me
han hecho
repasemos exactamente estos datos que
arroja el estudio de la universidad de
varsovia en 2017 el 28% de la población
lg de temas tenía algún síntoma de
depresión o de ansiedad esta cifra
aumentó hasta el 44 por ciento entre
2020 en el 2019 y 2020 recordemos que
además también fue el año pandémico
entonces hubo muchas personas que
quedaron en cuarentena das en sus casas
en espacios no seguros y la familiar no
te acepta como eres entonces el 20 por
ciento de los encuestados reportó haber
tenido que huir también de sus propias
casas labor estoy triste más la
organización mundial de la salud se
pronunció sobre la efectividad de las
vacunas y las dosis refuerzo hablamos
ahora la pandemia de ccoo bit décima
volvemos al cove' 19 es imposible huir
de ese tema la organización mundial de
la salud siempre va con un poco de
retraso no no son datos que no sepamos
pero al final eso es bueno porque
significa que sus conclusiones son más
sólidas y más estudiadas esto fue lo que
dijeron sobre la efectividad de las
vacunas
hay datos emergentes que muestran un
declive de la efectividad de las vacunas
contra la infección de sars cop 2 y el
19 con un declive más pronunciado en
adultos
pero los datos actuales muestran que las
vacunas tienen un nivel robusto de
protección contra la enfermedad severa
durante al menos seis meses aunque se ha
visto algo de caída contra la enfermedad
severa en personas mayores y personas
con condiciones médicas subyacentes
without the online medical connections
con estos datos en la mano la
organización mundial de la salud sigue
recomendando además que las dosis de
refuerzo sean para las personas en
riesgo de sufrir un kobe grave y no para
la población en general un mandato que
muchísimos gobiernos de nuestra global
raúl siguientes vientos hablemos de otra
protagonista de estos días la variante
omicron porque ayer salieron varios
estudios marc sobre esta vacuna de facer
20 contra esta variante que sabemos
hasta ahora claro precisamente hablando
de esa rapidez o lentitud a veces es
bueno tomarse las cosas con calma todos
esos estudios salieron ayer inundaron
muchos titulares pero es importante dar
un poco de contexto vamos con el primer
estudio fue un estudio del instituto de
salud de sudáfrica que habló de una gran
caída de la protección contra omicron de
la dosis de facer con dos dosis de la
vacuna pero la combinación en cambio de
los anticuerpos por infección previa con
la vacuna seguía protegiendo importante
decir este estudio ni siquiera está
publicado esta información se sacó de un
tuit del director del estudio y ni
siquiera tampoco se ha revisado por
otros científicos y la muestra fue con
12 personas para saber lo preliminar que
es este estudio otro de los del estudio
del hospital perdón universitario de
frankfurt concluyó que la protección de
las vacunas de facer contra omicron era
37 veces menor que contra delta pero
también importante este estudio sigue
sin estar publicado y se hizo con un
virus una especie de réplica sintética
del virus que no es real y no habla
exactamente de cómo se puede comportar
el sars co2 y por último está el estudio
de facer que también estuvimos el que
estuvimos hablando ayer que dicen que
tres dosis de la vacuna de ellos protege
contra la variante omicron pero no
publicaron ninguno de estos datos
entonces no sabemos bien en qué basan
esta conclusión eso no quiere decir que
no tengamos que escuchar toda esta
información al final en las personas que
están detrás de estos estudios son
científicos que están
adelante de la lucha contra la contra la
pandemia de ccoo bendiciones pero
tampoco tenemos que tomarnos los datos
como si fueran indiscutibles mar
hablamos de omicron alfa beta gamma pero
por qué se llama así esta nueva variante
es un nombre un poco amenazante no soy
total da miedo la verdad porque alfa
gama beta era como bueno pero o micrones
como bien el monstruo si suena suena muy
alarmante pero la verdad es que no lo
eligieron específicamente para esta
nueva variante recordemos que la o ms
decidió poner letras del alfabeto griego
para evitar la discriminación que podía
surgir de decir cosas como la variando
la nota nica claro o la variante
sudafricana entonces empezamos con la
variante alfa beta gamma y delta
variantes nombradas de preocupación a la
que se añadió omicron después no suelen
las primeras letras del alfabeto griego
luego lambda y muy por ejemplo son las
que se declararon de interés es decir
que deben seguirse de cerca y todas las
letras que quedaron entre delta y entre
lambda son variantes que antes eran de
interés pero que decidieron descartarse
entonces este vacío que queda entre muy
y omicron se descartaron esas letras por
un lado porque no podía confundirse con
new en inglés la palabra nuevo en inglés
y si es un apellido muy común en china y
otros países asiáticos sin ir más lejos
xi jinping por ejemplo presidente de
china y así fue como terminamos dando el
salto a omicron pero no es que lo
eligieran por un motivo de cómo suena de
amenazante la palabra como ves quedan
nueve letras más esperemos no llegar
nunca a omega raúl por lo menos dos
formas marc muchísimas gracias entonces
por toda la información de salud
nosotros vamos ahora a hablar con
nuestra segunda mitad del día